[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com well it happened Democrat
duck Jones has defeated serial alleged
child sex abuse or oi more in deeply
deeply read conservative Alabama but
just barely let's look at the results
from yesterday's special election of
course to fill the seat previously held
by now Attorney General Jeff Sessions
Doug Jones the Democrat winning with
just a hair under half of the vote
defeating Roy Moore by about one point
five percent of the vote which worked
out to just under twenty one thousand
votes you'll notice that the difference
between them under twenty one thousand
votes the total number of write-ins
nearly twenty three thousand votes a
bigger number of a bigger share of
write-ins than the difference between
Doug Jones and Roy Moore and we'll talk
about the implications of that because
there was a bit of a write-in campaign
even from some Republicans over the last
few days and that may have actually
sealed it for Doug Jones let's talk
about the implications for Democrats and
I'll talk about the implications for
Republicans for Democrats this is a
major win now it's not a landslide win
it is not a politically decisive win
that suggests that in three years when
there is the next election for this seat
it's going to go to a Democrat by
default it's possible but it's not the
most likely thing but this is a major
win for Democrats because it's a major
loss for Trump number one but we also
don't want to forget about the fact that
a Democrat hasn't held this seat for
something like 25 years and if Democrats
are winning in Alabama yes against one
of the worst candidates in the history
of candidates if Democrats are winning
in Alabama after 25 years what might
happen in the midterms in 2018 that is a
sign that is a positive
for Democrats and there is one more
Democratic vote in the Senate and it's
at a time when Democrats really need it
right it's it's not the most progressive
Democratic vote to that of Doug Jones
but still it's Alabama right you'll take
anything you can get it's to the left of
a Republican there and when it comes to
the agenda of Trump that extra vote may
actually be able to stop some pretty
important elements of the Trump agenda
for Trump this is terrible in every way
right number one first Donald Trump an
endorsed Luther strange in the
Republican primary in Alabama he was
running against Roy Moore Roy Moore won
the primary Trump immediately deleted
tweets where he had supported Luther
strange we then learned about multiple
allegations of child sexual assault
again against Roy Moore and then after
that Trump came out and endorsed Roy
Moore even going to Alabama for what was
just a general rally but clearly it was
meant to be a sort of de facto rally for
Roy Moore and then Roy Moore lost right
but the ways in which this is a loss for
Trump are huge number one another Trump
endorsed candidate lost yeah he didn't
endorse him until close to the end but
it was an endorsement and another Trump
endorsed candidate lost number two when
it comes to policy this might directly
impact the ability of Republicans to get
Obamacare repealed if they're going to
take that back up at some point in the
new year this win by Doug Jones could
directly impact whether the tax cut or I
call it the tax hike bill depending what
you call it is going to pass once it
gets back to the conference version and
then big one number three remember how
Trump said that if he had known that his
attorney general Jeff Sessions was going
to recuse himself on russia-related
matters he would have selected someone
else for attorney general to begin with
well this is also a seat that wouldn't
even have been open for a special
election had Jeff Sessions not been made
Attorney General just imagine the loser
failure of Donald Trump here he selects
an attorney general who immediately
recuse himself on Russia which directly
impacts Trump then the seat that his
decision vacates ends up having the
worst Republican
and it in recent history run for it and
lose and it gives a seat that has been
read for decades to Democrats very
low-energy for Trump as he likes to say
and Trump is just panicking on Twitter
to try to distance himself from more
after endorsing him it started sort of
okay last night Donald Trump tweeting
last night at just after 11:00 p.m.
Eastern Time congratulations to Doug
Jones on a hard-fought victory the
write-in votes played a very big factor
but a win is a win the people of Alabama
are great and the Republicans will have
another shot at this seed in a very
short period of time it never ends
actually he was right I mean the margin
of victory was smaller than the number
of write-in votes were which were
believed to be overwhelmingly favorable
to overwhelmingly for Republicans and
thus favorable to Doug Jones reasonable
point from Donald Trump
until he follows up with another tweet
this morning where he says the reason I
originally endorsed Luther strange and
his numbers went up mightily is that I
said Roy Moore will not be able to win
the general election I was right Roy
worked hard but the deck was stacked
against him
right Trump knew all along more wouldn't
win don't blame fit don't don't blame
him for this pandering once again I
think Trump is the only person who can
turn to losses in the same race and if
he loses in 2020 he'll probably try to
do the same thing this was a big victory
for me no question about it and you
can't really exculpate Trump for blank
from blame here because remember this
all happened because Trump pulled
sessions out of the Senate to become
Attorney General Trump is trying to
paint himself as the guy who if you had
just paid attention he endorsed Luthor
strange then Republicans would have won
you wouldn't even have had a special
election if it weren't for your decision
to take Jeff Sessions the live riddled
and totally depraved senator and made
him Attorney General to begin with
how could he have foreseen that though
you think that an Alabama Senate seat
would be safe in Republican hands I'd
really just because Roy Moore was a
horrible candidate and the multiple
sexual misconduct allegations and that's
what I want to talk about next there's
this line that pundits all over
corporate media have been have been
they've been lauding Republic
in Alabama saying you know even
Republicans in Alabama weren't gonna go
with the serial accused child sex
assault er they were that was even too
much for Alabama Republicans
no it wasn't most Alabama Republicans
voted for the accused serial child sex
assault er a few didn't and it happened
to be enough that Doug Jones ended up
winning by a slim margin but praising
Alabama Republicans like they've all
decided they had their so-called
come-to-jesus moment where they said we
can't vote for the accused serial sex
assault er no they didn't they mostly
voted for him Alabama Republicans at
large did a horrible thing here but
enough of you enough of them I don't
know how many are in my audience did the
right thing and didn't vote for Roy
Moore and really we have black people to
thank here and what David what are you
talking about black people to thank put
up the exit polling which showed us how
this race broke down based on both race
and gender 72% of white men voted for
Roy Moore sixty-three percent of white
women voted for Roy Moore but it was the
black men and women who together made up
28% of the total electorate that by more
than a 93% margin and black women by a
98% margin did not vote for Roy Moore
they really are the ones who flipped
this had it been left just to the
average Republican Roy Moore would be
the senator right now and what's
interesting is Roy Moore said that he'd
want to do away with all the amendments
after the 10th amendment right which
includes the 13th amendment banning
slavery the 15th amendment allowing
blacks to vote in the 19th amendment
allowing women to vote so apparently
black voters got the message here that
Roy Moore is not your guy yeah but white
women didn't Roy Moore would have won
with probably 80% of the vote had he
already successfully gotten rid of those
amendments that apparently he finds so
distasteful so a win for Democrats don't
expect that doug jones is going to be
reelected in 2020 because these were
very specific circumstances I hope he is
I hope he runs an is reelected major win
and used this to the advantage of the
Democrats until that 2020 election
yesterday as we were waiting for the
Rose
from the ROI more Doug Jones Alabama
special Senate election which ultimately
Doug Jones won defeating the alleged
serial child sex assault or Roy Moore
all sorts of interviews were happening
on television with campaign surrogates
and one of these surrogates is Roy Moore
spokesman Ted Crockett you're gonna like
Ted I think Roy Moore has previously
said that he doesn't believe Muslims
should be allowed in Congress now that's
an obviously unconstitutional position
from a guy who claims to be all about
the Constitution but that's not at at
hand that's not the subject of today's
discussion this guy Ted Crockett goes on
CNN Jake Tapper interviews him and asks
him perfectly reasonable question he's
the spokesman explained to us why Roy
Moore doesn't believe Muslims should be
allowed to serve in Congress and the
spokesman says we'll listen you got a
swear on a Christian Bible to be in
Congress and if you're Muslim you're not
going to be able to believably swear an
oath of office on a Christian Bible and
Jake Tapper explains to him no you
choose what you swear an oath on you can
choose a Christian Bible or a Hebrew
Bible or a Quran or nothing at all
doesn't really matter and Roy Moore
spokesman seems so stunned so taken
aback that he went totally silent now if
you're listening to this and not
watching you might think Oh David you
extended the silence to make it seem
like it was longer than it really was
no no we are going to play this clip for
you as it appeared originally on CNN the
silence has not been extended it is it's
full cringe-worthy reality take a listen
to this Judge Moore has also said that
he doesn't think a Muslim member of
Congress should be allowed to be in
Congress why under what under what
because you have to swear on the Bible
you and you you when you are before I
had to do it I'm an elected official
three terms I had to swear on a Bible
you have to swear on a Bible to be an
elected official in the United States of
America he alleges that a Muslim cannot
do that
ethically swearing on the Bible you
don't actually have to swear on a
Christian Bible you can swear on
anything really I don't know if you knew
that you can swear on Jewish Bible oh no
I've done it three times I'm sure you
have I'm sure you've picked a Bible but
the law is not that you have to swear on
a Christian Bible that is not the law
you don't know that all right Ted
Crockett well I don't know I know that
Donald Trump did it when he when we made
him present because he's Christian and
he picked it that's what he wanted to
that's we wanted to swear in on Ted
Crockett with the more campaign good
luck tonight thank you so much for being
here my panel will react thank you sir
I love at the end telling Jewish Jake
Tapper Merry Christmas just like every
detail about is this perfect well Trump
did it he swore on a Bible the guy's
mouth was hanging open and he was doing
this slow blink which makes it his brain
seemed to malfunction right how could it
be a choice to swear on a Christian
Bible it seems just impossible this is
possibly the dumbest and most confused
I've ever seen a member of Homo sapiens
look in the history of television and
the endless number of hours of political
interviews that I've ever watched I used
to just think that these people wanted
the u.s. to be a Christian theocracy
they don't get it they actually think it
is and that no wonder why they want the
Ten Commandments to be in court house
yeah if you believe that everyone has to
swear on a Christian Bible to be an
elected member of office why wouldn't
you think it's fine for the Ten
Commandments to be on public property
quite literally confirmation dot bias
and fallacy by example he's only ever
seen people swear on Christian Bibles so
you must be legally required to do that
just so embarrassing really shocking and
the problem is that this is like playing
chess with your dog right it doesn't
matter how obviously you win the dog is
not gonna notice and that's probably
what a lot of people who supported Roy
Moore would react to when they how they
would react when they see this which is
what's the big deal yeah you should be
swearing on a Christian you really
thought that he had the winning argument
here he really did hey a Trump sawr on
it I swore on it unbelievable and the
the guy that was represented
this person represents Roy Moore he
almost won right so we are just only buy
it buy it the tiniest bit out of the
would send me your thoughts about this
I'm on Twitter at the Pakman show is on
Twitter at david patten show the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is Michael Anderson Michael thank you so
much for being a david patten show
member membership is of course the top
funding source for our program you can
learn more and get access to the bonus
show and the commercial free audio
podcast and the commercial free video
feed which is just for members at david
pakman.com slash membership and you can
also with your membership get a free 20
18 david pakman show calendar which are
now available with all original 100%
original viewer created cartoon artwork
and other artwork it's fantastic
get the calendar free if you go to david
pakman.com slash calendar 18 you can
also make a pledge of as little as one
dollar per month at patreon.com slash
david pakman show and yes more and more
people foaming at the mouth from
excitement's that we are now accepting
cryptocurrency contributions learn more
at david pakman.com slash cryptocurrency
let's get into this week's hate reott
mail what is hatred mail this is hey
tree mail brace yourselves for the only
information that can successfully
penetrate a tinfoil hats
patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman like because America
and because freedom okay
alert this week's hatred mail contains
what may be a new slogan for what I
don't know but it may be a new slogan
for something take a listen
David Pakman the cuck starts here this
is fake news unsubscribe all you Jews
are sick David is a beta cooked soy boy
communist [ __ ] as well as his
regressive followers Mexicans and
Muslims here to destroy America you know
what's funny there are quite a few
congressmen that have visible and
audible signs of Alzheimer's dementia
Dianne Feinstein Nancy Pelosi Maxine
Waters John Conyers what do they all
have in common
the cuck starts here that is quite a
slogan I don't know for what it's not
gonna be the theme for the David Pakman
show but somebody should use that for
something and he said unsubscribe to
which believe that he would subscribe
for a while point yeah I do want to ask
you though Pat as a vegan you might be
familiar with this term what is the soy
boy there's been a couple times now that
people not just in hatred mail but on
like on YouTube as if they refer to me
as a soy boy yeah I think the Infowars
people and Paul Joseph Watson put out a
video about how soy is bad for your
health
yeah and it's been debunked many times
over and not only that one of the
products that Paul Joseph Watson
advertises for yeah has soy in it Oh
does it really yes what we so I do I
guess yeah so a boy I mean I know I know
about the from a digestive standpoint
this is hatred male we're talking about
digestion of soy I do believe that I've
read some some pretty good material
about its I think unfermented soy is not
good for women to have yeah I guess
there's debate over if it's healthy for
men to have to yeah because it has
estrogen but it's plant based estrogen
Jim which doesn't affect human hormone
level yeah yeah yeah I mean there's
there's a whole scientific discussion
that's probably beyond hey treatments
it's probably beyond the scope of the
[ __ ] starting here yeah that's for sure
okay anyway I am so boy David
Ackman and i'm here to tell you the cuck
starts here you can use the coupon code
patriot 40 this is a weird show you can
use the coupon code hey tree at 40 when
you get a membership at david pakman.com
slash membership it'll save you 40% it's
like a middle finger to the hey tree
'it's okay
I've got kind of a I don't like to bump
people out but I do like to tell you
what's going on earlier this week I
explained to you that as a result of
patreon shifting around how they handled
the fees on donations through that
platform the David Pakman show
fundraisers through patreon at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
patreon decided to shift some of the
burden of the fees on the platform
towards the donor and away from the
recipient and this was a disastrous idea
from patreon partially because it was a
bad idea to begin with and additionally
because it was messaged terribly and it
led to nearly 200 patrons canceling
their contributions to the David Pakman
show
I got a voicemail saying David do you
see what people are saying on your video
about the patreon situation here's that
voicemail that came in
hi David this is Tim I just wanted to
say that I think it's really [ __ ] up
how's you been getting defunded left and
right so I just became a member and then
I saw your video called patreon is
killing us and oh my goodness crystal
all those comments was really mean like
I know that there's a lot of youthful
trolls out there but damn do you have a
lot of YouTube troll so I wanted to say
for you and Pat to [ __ ] the haters thank
you doing what you're doing and good
luck after we received this voicemail I
said you know it's been so busy I
haven't even seen the comments on that
YouTube video about the problems we're
having with patreon and it's absolutely
vile and disgusting people are jumping
for joy proverbially over the problems
we're having with patreon funding I'll
put just a couple of these comments up
on the screen for you one user called
seeking truth 2014 Wow Wow
I don't want to get a real job Wow what
a nuanced and productive critique of the
problem we're having pretty sure this is
a real job - I thought it was I thought
it was if my accountant has
tricked all this time into thinking that
I'm actually working then I really have
to apologize to him also haha
David cockman ship is sinking another
user on YouTube still begging for money
get a job scumbag yeah that comes up a
lot that this isn't a real job okay this
is your business
it has employees this is this is what we
do I get up in the morning put my pants
on three legs at a time and come in here
you know what we love I think that's
where they're jealous of absolutely
right
also haha glad David Pakman is failing I
think we've got one or two more here
maybe not one more good I hope you're
centrist pro corporate pro military
intervention pro Russia hysteria and pro
apartheid channel gets wiped out same
thing happened when we announced that
our Amazon affiliate link had been
turned off I mean just totally cancelled
and two months of revenue would not be
paid to us people rejoicing rejoicing in
the streets Trump incorrectly claimed
that like thousands of people in New
Jersey were cheering 9/11 or something
like that we actually have the real
evidence that when we lost our Amazon
link and patreon made this change which
really hurt us there were hundreds and
hundreds of people on the internet
rejoicing that we'll have proof of but I
mean we can't let the hatreds win here
that we can't do
no absolutely not I'm hoping that there
are more good people that are silent and
are contributing and that they sort of
overpower the scum that want us to fail
ok I've got a major story to talk to you
about here about something that is not
good that is going on remember last week
when I told you that all right troll
Mike Serna vich started a campaign to
get friend of the show Sam cedar host of
the majority report a voice actor on
Bob's Burgers formerly of Air America
radio formerly of one episode of Sex in
the City anyway we all know Sam cedar at
this point he tweeted about Roman
Polanski about eight years ago that
tweet was taken out of context to make
it seem as though he was sort of
minimizing the horrible actions called
sexual assault by Roman Polanski Mike
Serna vich this alt-right troll with a
pretty big online following started a
campaign
basically to get Sam cedar fired from
MSNBC and to have his advertisers pull
money from his program he got fired from
MSNBC did Sam cedar until eventually
MSNBC realized that they had sort of not
considered the cynical objectives of
Serna vich and his cronies and MSNBC
said they would be reinstating Sam cedar
that's a good thing now the problem is
that in defending Sam cedar on the David
Pakman show I inadvertently got myself
on the radar of Mike Serna vich and he
now has created a similar online stink
which is leading to hundreds of emails
to Boston College where I am an adjunct
professor demanding that I be fired for
an offensive tweet I'm going to show you
the tweet I am NOT going to be deleting
the tweet it is up on my account I
tweeted last night what I thought was a
pretty clever tweet which was after the
results are in tonight the voters of
Alabama are going to have to reckon with
the reality that win or lose they live
in Alabama now when you look at that
you'll see that there are something like
close to 2000 or even more responses to
this a couple hundred retweets this
tweet got a lot of activity and the
reason that it got a lot of activity is
that Mike Serna vich or more likely
someone told him about it and then he
tweeted about it decided to go after me
for this tweet first Mike's turn of its
retweeted it then he actually
screenshotted it and commented saying is
this what the media thinks about Alabama
first of all the idea that a tweet from
me is a tweet that could in any way
represent quote the media is laughable
right I host a small independent show in
what way does anything I say reflect
what the media thinks about any issue
this is a sign that we made it maybe
right it's almost flattering and how
outrageous it is but most importantly of
course my tweet is referring to the fact
that Alabamans have been raped and
pillaged by Republicans for decades and
I made that clear in a follow-up tweet
there was a recent UN investigation that
says Alabama has the worst poverty of
the developed world it's a total
disaster and I clarified that in a tweet
where I said this is a criticism of
how Republicans have failed Alabama
education health care public
infrastructure it is not a criticism of
the people although there will be plenty
to criticize about the people who vote
for Roy Moore doesn't matter though
Serna vich is followers after failing to
get Sam cedar fired from MSNBC are
trying to give me the same treatment
they are after me they are sending
tweets to Boston College where I am an
adjunct professor of communications they
are sending emails to Boston College and
I actually I didn't know what to do
because now I'm the target of what I was
just trying to talk about last week when
it came to Sam cedar I reached out to
Boston College this morning and I
explained listen this is who Mike Serna
vich is before you hear about this from
anybody else I want to let you know
about what's going on just so you're
aware of the full scope of my tweets who
this guy is what happened to Sam cedar
etc that aside and hopefully I won't get
fired from Boston College it is
endlessly funny to me how the people who
claim that there's oppressive political
correctness and limits on free speech
and no one has a sense of humor anymore
and they're against safe spaces they are
apoplectic ly playing the outrage card
here they are just outraged because I
made a joke where they misinterpreted
that what I'm doing is making fun of
people in Alabama which if that's what I
was doing it's not really that offensive
I mean it's a pretty mild joke and of
course what I was really doing is
criticizing the politics of Alabama
which are absolutely atrocious see what
a snowflake - right and that this guy is
failed over and over again yeah whether
it be the pizza gate conspiracy that
completely collapsed trying to get Sam
cedar fired actually went on Alex Jones
a show a couple times oh it was a
disaster herbal performance horrible
before if you haven't seen Serna vich on
alex jones check that out yeah I think
that maybe there's some element of Serna
vich being really angry that he didn't
succeed at getting Sam fired I don't
know I mean so far not knock on lucite
I've not yet been fired by Boston
College I picked up thousands of new
Twitter followers as a result because
this got so much attention and by the
way the degree of anti-semitic pond scum
that started coming after me after Serna
vich sic them on me last night is really
really stunning yeah but not surprising
not surprising at all though
and finally I feel bad for the people of
Alabama in Massachusetts we are somewhat
protected from the horrible things that
the current federal administration the
Trump administration is doing we're
still going to suffer if Trump gets his
way on all fronts but I really feel bad
for people like in Indiana where I where
I recently was an economically ravaged
state that is only going to be further
crushed by the Trump agenda Alabama is
another example I actually feel bad the
last thing I'm doing is making fun of
the people of Alabama I am really
feeling bad that they are being crushed
by the agendas of politicians like
Donald Trump that's what's going on I
will let you know if this becomes a
firing from Boston College you can
discuss this with us on reddit a david
pakman.com slash re deit
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
it's great to be joined today by Tom
Nichols who is a professor and also
author of the book the death of
expertise this is a really interesting
topic to me and I'm so glad to have you
on to talk about it the idea of
expertise particularly in the media
world and in the political world has
been an increasingly important topic no
really no matter what political issues
one follows give us sort of a general
sense of what you identified as being an
issue within the world of expertise that
led you to write this book in the first
place
well the what I initially reacted to was
not people doubting expertise I mean
that's normal if you're a professional
you kind of get used to that I mean
people seek second opinions from doctors
they go get a second opinion from a
lawyer they get multiple bids from
contractors what led me to write the the
initial blog post because it this wasn't
even a book
it was kind of a ranch was people
deciding that they were smarter than
experts and specifically in one evening
people who decided they were smarter
than me about Russia I had a young
person tell me we were talking about the
Edward Snowden business on a young
person said to me tell me I don't think
you understand Russia now I'm a Russia
expert a Russian speaking Russian expert
at but in the business you know thirty
years and that finally kind of you know
popped my top when someone said you know
let me explain Russia to you and this
had actually been germinating for a
while I've been talking up until that
point with people who were experts and
things like intelligence doctors you
name it just in random conversations
where they said yeah you know people
keep lecturing me about what I'm good at
and that's what kind of triggered the
idea wasn't that people doubt experts or
have concerns about expertise it was
my experiences along with those of other
experts and professionals who were
really puzzled by people explaining I
suppose you know a lot of women have
said to me this is what mansplaining
feels like but people explaining your
own area of expertise back to you as
though you don't really understand it
yeah and I've noticed that there a
particulate we don't have to get into
them but there are particular political
issues where this is really prevalent
one is certainly climate change and
climate science and there's a lot of
others that we could talk about it seems
that there is this complexity because
you do on the one hand have a logical
fallacy called the appeal to Authority
right suggesting that something either
is right or couldn't be right based on
the perceived or actual sort of
authority of the person making an
assertion but that is very separate from
the reality that training and education
in subjects do contribute to expertise
so how can we sort of square or or put
together those two sides well one of
most important things about the fallacy
of the appeal to authorities that most
people don't understand it they don't
understand that when someone says look
you know you should listen to me about
Russia because I'm an expert on Russia
they say oh well that's just an appeal
to Authority that's not an appeal to
Authority that's presenting their bona
fides appeal to Authority is saying
because I'm you know a professor you
should listen to me about you know
health care or exercise or something
people never understand this that that
they have really become allergic that
when someone says look I'm a doctor you
know you should listen to me about your
heart they say oh that's an appeal to
Authority they think that it means any
Authority is an appeal to Authority and
you know it's an irony that in the death
of expertise when people argue about
expertise they don't even understand the
fallacies they're using and of course if
you correct them then you're being
condescending and an expert and all the
things that people hate I think though
the way one way to square in this
problem is that experts and I think this
is one place I I could have improved the
book if I may do some self criticism is
that experts need to be better about
explain
why they're right I admit that I kind of
lose my patience with people who say
well why should I listen to you because
at some point you do run out of patience
with that it's like yes it'd be like a
student walking into class every day and
saying well I know you're the professor
and I know you were hired by Boston
College to teach this course but tell me
again why I should listen to you on the
other hand I think you need to be
persuasive and I think you do need to
put out your case and you do need to be
willing to go that distance as long as
people are willing to listen to you in
good faith which i think is another
problem in in the modern this modern
phenomenon of death of expertise people
just aren't willing to listen how much
has basically Google I guess is what we
would call it or the availability of
opinion about just about any issue on
the internet impacted the sort of
perceived credibility of experts well I
find it fascinating that people who
don't trust New York Times don't trust
the Washington Post don't trust the Wall
Street Journal don't trust college
professors don't trust science will
trust any stray bit of detritus that
goes in front of their screen on the
Internet
I still argue and I would still argue
now and I argued in the book that this
whole phenomenon predates the Internet
I really think this is an outcome of the
late 1960s and relevance and higher
education and therapeutic models of
education child rearing and a lot of
other problems that contributed to an
overall increase in narcissism in
American society but the Internet is an
easy crutch you know because it allows
us to just find basically it allows us
to confirm anything we already believe
and I find that it's I find it amazing
that people who say well I need evidence
and I don't just take the words of
experts will go and type in a search
term term in Google and just accept
whatever pops up in further eyes because
it's pretty it's easy to read it's well
presented you know one of the great
curses of the Internet is that anything
in 12-point font looks authoritative
and I think that you know that's that is
a real problem it's it's not the source
of the depth of expertise but it's
really something that's put it on
steroids how much does this connect to
the sort of pseudo-intellectual movement
that's been in the United States now
more and more strongly over the last
decades I've made the case and
reasonable people can disagree but I've
made the case that pseudo-intellectual
ism is in many ways more dangerous than
anti intellectualism once you have
people reading you know Bill O'Reilly
book about the death of Abraham Louie
the life of Abraham Lincoln or the death
of day of care whatever and believing
that they are scholars of history for
example or reading books by people like
Mark Levin and Laura Ingraham or whoever
that their belief that they have sort of
explored a variety of viewpoints from
experts etc that that can actually be
more dangerous than just straight out
anti intellectualism I'd be curious to
hear your thoughts and also if and how
this connects to expertise well I I
don't I guess I would part company with
you on the semantics I don't think of
you know Bill O'Reilly books as
pseudo-intellectual I think of them as
anti intellectual I really do so I guess
I should say they are perceived as maybe
intellectual by some of the audience of
for them oh they I mean away you know
why do people like Bill O'Reilly books
because they it seems to arm you with
knowledge without actually making you do
the work and I I think you know pseudo
intellectual ism maybe you know this is
just a semantic difference but I don't
really encounter pseudo intellectual ism
as much as I used to say in the 70s or
the 80s people whose people for example
when I think of a pseudo intellectual I
say I think of someone who says oh yes
you know I find Camus so tiresome when
in fact you know this person has never
read Camus you know or you know I have
some very deep thoughts on
reconstruction and the post slavery you
know period when you know this is not a
person who ever thought about it
anti-intellectualism says I don't really
need an informed opinion about this my
gut in fact my opinion is better about
this because I'm just a working Joe you
know you know why Bill O'Reilly
books are better because he's not a
professor he's not one of you snotty
over educated footnoting kind of
intellectuals he's just an ordinary guy
just like you and me and that's why his
books are great and I think that's
actually more dangerous because it's not
just junk
it's tasty junk it's it's yummy junk you
know I mean books I I tried reading
killing Reagan because it's an area I
have a lot of knowledge in it I'm cool I
have some background as a cold war
historian and I you know I was alive
during Reagan I'm working in Washington
and it's crap but it's easy to read crap
so it's not even like the I guess
pseudo-intellectuals lie about difficult
books they can't read anti intellectuals
really do read bad books and celebrate
it and glory in it and I'm speaking of
the of textbooks I mean because you
mentioned Bill O'Reilly not a professor
in the book you have a chapter called
higher ed the customer is always right
can you tell us a little bit about how
that factors into this yeah I think you
know College when it was a natural
sorting function for know let me back up
and say college was also you know
class-based
experience wealthier kids went you know
not ever kid that you know John F
Kennedy went to Harvard and he was a C
student I mean this was not always the
the province of bright kids it was off
in the province of rich kids but College
throughout the 50s and 60s and into the
70s needs to serve to store natural
sorting function that you know if you
went to college because you were really
interested in going to college now
college is a mass experience we really
do we really have internalized this
belief that everybody should go to
college and the problem is that devalues
a college education because the
competition for those tuition dollars
excuse me the competition for those
tuition dollars really does make
colleges the lower tier colleges not not
not Harvard and Yale I mean Harvard and
Yellow Rose can have their valedictorian
but it makes middle and lower tier
colleges have to compete for students
and
my clients rather than students and that
means that you're not going to fail the
customer you're not gonna make them
uncomfortable you're not going to be too
challenging you start adverts as I talk
in the book talk about the book you
start advertising things like dorms that
our little apartment so you don't have
to pick roommates that you don't like
rock climbing and kayaking and basically
a whole bunch of things that really had
nothing to do with education when you
treat students like clients you're not
treating them like students College is
supposed to be uncomfortable it's
supposed to be where you get challenged
and you know there are times you should
walk out of class really unhappy but we
live in a therapeutic culture where you
know especially in an educational
culture where the students are always
supposed to be happy and we're always
asking them if they're happy and I think
that's really contributing to the
inability to keep learning even after
college and everything that's it doesn't
mean much now when a student says well I
have a university education that that
may or may not mean anything anymore but
it convinces that student I'm smart I I
don't really need to learn more than I
know and they're not really equipped to
keep learning and I think that's that's
a real tragedy in Western education
we've been speaking about the book the
death of expertise with the book's
author Tom Nicholls thanks so much for
talking to us about this very
interesting
thanks for Avenida the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
so yesterday I told you that I had
received an email from a viewer with a
link to a video that makes it look as
though in 2012 on stage with MIT Romney
and his wife Ann Romney Donald Trump
might have grabbed the rear end of an
Romney we have the video where we played
we played this video yesterday and we'll
show it to you again today and it's a
moment where Mitt Romney is speaking and
you see Donald Trump sort of shift in a
weird way and Ann Romney seems to almost
like be startled into moving slightly
forward or shifting her buttocks and
Donald Trump when that happens has a
really strange look on his face and
again I presented this not because I
necessarily thought anything in
particular was going on but because a
viewer had pointed it out to me and it
was weird and I mostly expected that
this would disappear and that would kind
of be the end of it well a user on our
YouTube channel went back and found more
video of this same event and pointed out
that Ann Romney as soon as the speech is
over very awkwardly sort of walks away
from Trump and doesn't shake his hand or
anything we got a message there was a
comment left on our YouTube channel
about this and it says David you could
be onto something found the original on
YouTube she even seems to frown towards
the end notice how she quickly leaves
the stage she didn't shake Trump's hand
it seems odd so I went and looked at
that video and it is exactly as this
YouTube viewer describes watch and
Romney as the speech ends leaning away
from Trump and getting out of there just
immediately without shaking Donald
Trump's hand kind of stepping away and
pointing to someone maybe she had to go
and speak to somebody in the crowd
whatever but again individually none of
these are definitive evidence that
Donald Trump did anything the dynamic is
very very strange here though and Ann
Romney stepping away and opting not to
shake hands with Donald Trump after
reacting strangely at a moment where
Trump does seem to reach for something
with his right hand and then have this
weird doofy look on his face
I don't know I'm presenting to you what
I'm seeing this is all coming from the
audience I don't know whether we will
ever learn any more
about this but it is certainly now two
pieces of sort of unusual video from
this exact same incident yeah I wonder
how hard it would be to reach out to an
romney on this one maybe i'm sure she
made the decision that if this did
happen not to say he didn't want to go
public with it certainly in 2012 when
mit romney was running yeah or even in
the 2016 race when Donald Trump had
multiple sexual misconduct allegations
made against him and it would have been
an opportune time for her to say hey you
know what when I was on stage in 2012 he
did so yeah she could certainly put this
to bed with just one sentence but in the
meantime more and more of our audience
thinking hey David that there is
something weird going on there hey so I
have a Keurig on the table with me and I
want to make super clear that this is
not a product placement this is not an
advertising of any kind in fact I don't
like Keurig machines but I do have a
Keurig machine on the desk with me today
what's the backstory of this you might
remember that there was this rash of
videos by conservatives angrily
destroying and setting on fire they're
tearing machines after Keurig pulled
advertising from Sean Hannity's Fox News
TV show when he sort of seemed to defend
Roy more by saying at least some of his
victims had consented to sexual contact
with Roy more and conservatives went
crazy destroying their cure eggs now
it's no secret that I have serious
disdain for the coffee of Keurig
machines I think it's absolutely
terrible coffee well Matt a viewer got
in touch with me and he said hey David
listen I just switched from a Keurig to
one that makes good coffee
I was just gonna toss this but I thought
since cure eggs come up on your program
maybe I would send you the used Keurig
machine he insisted on sending it in and
now we have it so the question is what
do we do do we destroy the Keurig
machine not for anything having to do
with Sean Hannity's program but simply
because the Keurig makes bad coffee some
people might think we were destroying it
over the Hannity thing which I guess
that would be kind of the fun of it if
people thought that's why we were
destroying it and it turns out I just
don't think cure eggs make good coffee
the other side of it like the really
boring thing to do would be we just give
the Keurig to Pat because he likes
keyrings yeah big fan of Keurig over
here
although the audience isn't going to
decide that I mean they'd much rather
see you destroy it or me destroy it or
something else
entertainment so my question is what
else could we do with this Keurig
machine that's been donated we've
acquired it at no cost right so we can
destroy it we can do whatever the the
lost value of it is not an issue matt
has generously donated it donated it and
said do whatever you want
destroy it set it on fire blow it up or
just give it to Pat so he can make
coffee I'm open to hearing suggestions
from the audience so that's why I'm
talking about this today the Keurig is
sitting here with me if you have any
ideas of what we might be able to do
with this thing that would be funny
might help fundraise or whatever we can
give away a signed Keurig if someone
wanted it with some fundraising goal I
have no idea I don't know if this will
put the Keurig scandal to rest or yes
reopen the next chapter right I think if
you destroyed a Keurig it might end this
entire sort of love affair that has
caused so much controversy between you
and Keurig if you were willing to
destroy it be a ritual wouldn't it the
question is what would you destroy it
with like a baseball bat or bare hands
with your bare hands how else could a
Keurig be destroyed I don't know who's a
whole video people setting it on fire
set it on drawing a pool yeah I don't
know what I don't know ours running it
over with a car would be interesting
actually yeah so send in your thoughts
we'll do something with this but I don't
know of what what people want us to do
and if what you want is for Pat to take
the keurig and for me to never mention
it again that's also an acceptable path
forward right we're sort of open to that
as well we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine to david p here
is a voicemail that came in today um so
what question I'm um I'm assuming you're
probably familiar with the show Real
Time with Bill Maher yes if asked would
you go on and of course thank you yeah a
lot of times we get voicemails like
these would I be willing to appear and
oftentimes Bill Maher is the one that's
mentioned of course I would it would be
huge publicity if I was invited onto the
Bill Maher program you think you get the
ten-minute interview no just be one of
the panelists I think if I were invited
on the Bill Maher program and there's no
indication that that's
happen as if now although I would love
it and please email them and tweet them
and tell them to invite me I think I
would definitely be on the panel I don't
think at this point my status I'm not my
LOI innopolis you know my logo the ten
minutes sit down with bill maher I am
not deserving of that milah was so
famous that other people decided to pull
themselves off of the show because
merely because he was appearing yeah so
of course I would appear with Bill Maher
and I would encourage people in the
audience hey listen if that's something
that's of interest maybe let's get a
little campaign going to get me on there
that the scope with which that would
move the needle for the David Pakman
show is significant that is a show I've
been on CNN I've been on Fox News it did
very little in terms of bringing
audience to the show and even sometimes
it was a longer appearance like on CNN I
was on for I was the only guest being
interviewed by Aaron Bernal for longer
than I was on Fox News it did barely
anything for our web traffic YouTube
subscribers whatever I think Bill Maher
underpin appearance I'm Bill Maher would
do a lot yeah especially cuz you think
of CNN is more of a general audience Fox
News viewers aren't gonna tune in to you
after because they're not serve it is
but Bill Maher's audience is largely
progressives yeah and I think that that
would actually be huge I think appearing
on the Bill Maher program and the Joe
Rogan program both are formats that
would lend themselves to a lot of new
people coming into the the universe of
the David Pakman show on the bonus show
today America's healthiest and least
healthy states San Francisco is using
robots to drive away the homeless and
people are not happy and we will talk
about human feet washing up on the
Pacific Northwest what is that all about
we will talk about all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show two ways
to get the bonus show one get a
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership to become a patron for at
least five bucks a month at patreon.com
slash david pakman show and remember way
over here now we do have the 2018
calendars available for free with
membership
at david pakman.com slash calendar eight
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]